[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du
sepik loisirs vos idées sorties dans le
département on commence ensuite avec le
sommaire nous parlerons musique
classique et spectacle théâtral et
musical à plaisir en plateau le
directeur du théâtre espace coluche nous
présentera les prochains événements à
venir et pendant tout le mois de mars
une trentaine de créateurs vont investir
la boutique capsule market de versailles
une opération du groupe délire de
créatrice nous avons rencontré demande
qui présenteront leur travail et enfin
qui n'a jamais rêvé de participer à un
bal renaissance apprendre à danser comme
les nobles de la cour c'est possible et
mélanie poké nous dira comment est on
commence par une exposition aux
clayes-sous-bois dessin cousu de céline
nouvelle est à découvrir jusqu'au 19
mars à l'espace philippe noiret
l'artiste this coup et assemble ses
oeuvres un résultat en résultat un
mélange de couleurs de motifs et de
textures on écoute l'artiste nous en
dire plus patrick jacques de dixmude est
allé à sa rencontre
le fait de coudre à ça permet à la fois
de dessiner de transpercer d'assemblée
donc ça démultiplie les possibilités par
rapport au dessin où on glisse en
surface ça ça rend également possible
l'arrivée l'insertion de matériaux très
varié qui ajoute je pense une
sensibilité au final qui se perçoit une
fragilité intéressante entre les deux
matériaux tissus et papiers samedi
débute la 32e édition de mort par une
sorte une centaine d'artistes amateurs
locaux sera exposée jusqu'au 12 mars à
l'espace albert camus l'occasion aussi
de découvrir la beauté du travail de
juliette frescaline invité d'honneur et
présidente du jury chargé de la
sélection des oeuvres et comme chaque
année les amateurs de timbres ont rendez
vous ce week end l'association
philatélique de maurepas organise sa
traditionnelle exposition 14 adhérents
feront découvrir leurs collections
jusqu'à dimanche à la maison de sologne
plus de détails avec le président de
l'association la philatélie
jusqu'à présent se contenter de classer
les timbres dans l'ordre dans lequel il
paraissait dans lequel les émeutes et
les offices postaux actuellement on est
sur une philatélie plus moderne qui est
une philatélie thématiques sur des
sujets comme le l'économie d'énergie ou
les énergies du futur des choses comme
ça
[Musique]
et c'est maintenant le moment de parler
concerts spectacles et théâtre avec
notre invité vincent desmans le
directeur du théâtre espace coluche de
plaisir est avec nous pour présenter les
prochains rendez-vous bonjour vincent
bon jour et les prochains rendez vous ça
commence dès demain justement avec de la
musique classique vous recevez
l'orchestré national d'île de france
voilà ce sont des grands habitués du
théâtre espace coluche et demain c il
sillonne brusque hinault avec l'accent
et oeuvre de jeunesse de rossini opéra
mis en scène sans décor sans l'amérique
costumes et mise en scène scénographie
et donc c'est à 20h30 valeur précisons
que c'est un opéra et que le concert
dure 1h20 et non quatre heures comme la
plupart des opéras donc c'est
relativement accessible à tous même les
plus jeunes parce que pas soigné c'est
totalement accessible d'abord parce que
rossini et accessible et en plus voilà
une heure vingt on a le temps de rentrer
dans la musique d'entrer dans l'action
et c'est drôle en plus ce qui vous gâche
rien alors j'ai évoqué les plus jeunes
on va justement parlé un petit peu plus
après six ans puisqu'un spectacle
mercredi justement s'adresse aux enfants
dès l'âge de 5 ans voilà c'est sinbad le
marin oeuvre bien connu avec une mise en
scène très pointue très compétent
cordeau très très acérées très bien fait
mêlant à la fois comme il dit le jeu le
théâtre d'ombrés est fait par exemple
heures 50 minutes c'est à 15h30 et les
adultes aussi y trouvent leur compte
dans tous ces spectacles jeune public du
mercredi
et vous l'avez dit justement c'est un
spectacle polyvalent qui a dit
musique je veux marionnettes on l'a vu
un petit peu à l'image et mais je pense
que de mieux pour s'en rendre compte
c'est justement de regarder un petit
extrait et on se retrouve juste après
demain je vais devenir un homme
[Musique]
nombreux et tout
alors je dis que ça donne ça s'adressait
aux enfants mais en fait il ya également
une lecture pour les adultes c'est
vraiment un conte philosophique aussi à
tout le monde d'aller comprend le
message tout à fait et puis vous avez vu
il ya de la marionnette il ya absolument
tous les arts sont réunis en un seul
spectacle ça c'est très fort justement
qu'est ce qui fait l'intérêt de ce
spectacle c'est qu'un peu tout on
s'ennuie jamais il ya toujours des
choses à voir en fait l'histoire
l'histoire déjà effectivement que ce
soit pour les enfants pour les adultes
il ya du visuel il ya de la parole de la
musique la musique jouée en direct sans
vraiment c c'est à voir
on va juste se parler à un petit peu
plus loin là c'est la semaine prochaine
vendredi prochain le 10 mars une pièce
de théâtre les chatouilles qui sera
jouée alors qu'est ce que c'est des
chatouilles c'est le spectacle auquel je
tiens beaucoup qui a été un énorme buzz
à avignon qui est très poignant c'est
l'histoire car l'histoire est pas simple
telle histoire d'inceste
alors on va dire ouf mais comme je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est c'est
tellement bien fait toute la partie
quotidienne jouer et jouer justement
donc c'est drôle c'est on voit la petite
fille qui raconte ses livres ainsi
qu'une jeune femme qui joue bien sûr et
tout ce qui est indicible
là je rentre pas dans les détails tout
ce qui est indicible et danser et c'est
une extraordinaire danseuse aussi cette
comédienne je peux vous dire qu'à chaque
représentation le public est debout
c'est fantastique on s'insurge un petit
peu douloureux il ya également des
moments où
on rigole quand on respire on respire
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit bah voilà la vie
la vie voilà c'est comment cette jeune
femme cette jeune fille se reconstruit
sur ce qui lui est arrivé ces traités
aussi avec un petit peu de légèreté soit
trop trop en avoir un petit peu
voilà un mot sur justement la
programmation générale de l'espace du
théâtre espace coluche qui est très
varié c'est être accessible vraiment à
tout le monde c'est la ligne artistique
fixé par la ville la ville souhaite que
ce soit éclectique diversifiée
s'adressant à tous donc ça va vraiment
je reprends de la phrase bête avait même
pas de 7 ans a commencé à 5 ans même ça
commence à 3 ans puisqu'on est des
spectacles scolaires pour les tout
petits
donc c'est trois ans a très bien merci
beaucoup
votre classement directeur du théâtre
espace coluche à d'être venu sur le
plateau de tv fil 78 et on le rappelle
pour les prochains spectacles à venir ou
ceux qui sont beaucoup plus lointain en
tout cas ils sont tous à retrouver sur
leur site internet
merci beaucoup merci à vous et dès lundi
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars le groupe
d'élire deux créatrices prend ses
appartements chez capsule markets
une trentaine de créateurs de toute la
france exposeront leur travail
nous en avons rencontré deux à
versailles regarder une invitation au
voyage inspiré de ses différents séjours
solène a vécu en guyane une région
qu'elle continue de peindre pour
préparer son exposition chez capsule
markets
alors je vais présenter c'est ce style
d'oeuvres là parce que sept
cette soeur et ce est la première que
j'ai montré sur facebook et c'est grâce
à elle que je me suis dit que je pouvais
en faire mon métier parce qu'elle a
beaucoup plus donc c'est la forêt
guyanaise la forêt amazonienne et à tous
qui amérindiens et tout ça c'est
complètement passionnant et du coup les
peindre pour moi c'est vraiment une
passion de la forêt tropicale à la
montagne mais aussi des tableaux plus
enfantin l'artiste fait partie du groupe
délire de créatrice qui compte plus de
200 membres sur internet
clotilde a rejoint le groupe depuis sa
création il ya deux ans elle aussi
présentera son travail notamment ses
boîtes à bouchon le vin fait partie de
notre terroir
le terroir c'est important et on
s'aperçoit que beaucoup de gens gardent
leurs bouchons de vin j'ai découvert ça
un petit peu par hasard à la suite de
demandes de clientes que beaucoup de
personnes ont un vase impôts quelque
chose qui gardent les bouchons et on m'a
demandé de faire une vitrine pour les
exposer le coloris de la vitrine est
complètement adapté aux désirs du client
m'a demandé du vert du bleu on m'a même
envoyé un morceau de tissu pour la
sortie aux bleus de tels rideau
on me le demande très souvent pour faire
des cadeaux pour les papas autres
spécialités pour les plus jeunes cette
fois ses marque-pages magnétique
jusqu'au 1er avril le public retrouvera
le travail de clotilde et solène parmi
les oeuvres d'une trentaine de créateurs
[Musique]
et cette semaine nous faisons un bond
dans l'histoire mélanie poquet vont nous
emmener à la renaissance pour assister
en balles comme à l'époque c'est ça ça
se passe ce week-end et c'est les élèves
des conservatoires de versailles et de
viroflay qui vous invite à danser comme
on a pu le faire il ya 500 ou 600 ans le
meilleur de bâle sera frédéric martin un
violoniste alors ce balai donnés par une
quarantaine d'enfants des deux
conservatoires il y a des flûtistes il
ya des violonistes il ya des kabilistes
on le voit à l'image et ce sont les
élèves de trois professeurs qui
alterneront de la danse et de la musique
ils sont tous issus des premiers cycles
du conservatoire leurs professeurs
voulait leur composer une animation pour
leur faire comprendre notamment
l'importance du rythme c'est plutôt un
spectacle avec participation du public
parce que le bal est ouvert aux parents
aux amis aux frères et soeurs qui
souhaitent venir danser mais
également bien sûr à nos élèves puisque
soit ils sont en train de danser soit
ils sont en train de jouer sur scène
s'adresse aux amis à la famille mais les
curieux peuvent aussi venir ça ils sont
ils seront même très très content parce
qu'en plus la salle où va se dorer se
dérouler le bal et il a une capacité de
200 personnes il faut pas être un
musicien ou un danseur aguerris ce bal
est avant tout un moyen de découvrir un
héritage musical français découvrir
aussi qu'elle danse était pratiquée à la
con mais pas seulement
il y aura des brandes l'allemande de la
gavotte de la gaillarde et bien d'autres
et pour vous donner un petit aperçu de
ce qu'ils vont vous proposer un extrait
en rejeter enregistré lors d'une
répétition le morceau s'appelle le
branle de la torche et il date de 1712
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors petite précision ce n'est pas 1712
comme j'étais juste avancé 1612 et si
vous voulez vous laisser tenter
rendez vous le samedi 4 mars à la salle
dunoyer de ségonzac à viroflay
ça commence à 18h30 par contre une
réservation est nécessaire pour cela
rien de plus simple direction le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
le ballet sur la page d'accueil à la
rubrique les rendez vous merci beaucoup
mais la nuit pour cette présentation si
vous vous sentez l'âme d'un noble le
temps d'une après-midi vous savez où
vous rendre et c'est maintenant le
moment de l'agenda avec une dernière
date à noter ce week-end ne manquez pas
le départ de paris-nice dimanche à bois
d'arcy à 13 heures mais avant pour
patienter un village d'animations est
installé tout le week end devant la
mairie il y aura des défilés de vélos
des jeux et des stands maquillage et
photos il y en aura pour tous les goûts
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]